for you are you doing this new album
straight Indie yeah bankroll and
everything yeah everything what
producers are you working with
I mean I'm working with quite a few
producers you know what I'm saying some
guys from the East I got a
Trey and some of them guys that did like
you know some of my [__] on my on my
older projects you know what I'm saying
um mustard I did you know you reckon
with mustard yeah
is that gonna be a single
uh
probably they're like you get a mustard
beat I mean I mean yeah you know I'm
still putting it together you know what
I'm saying I'm still putting the whole
album together I like to finish like
everything you know and then and then I
always been the kind of guy that
finished everything and and then pick my
singles except for like king of Chevys I
was just like you know it was on the
podcast first and everything you know it
was just one of them records we was just
having fun you know but
the red printer is a is a good solid
project